with reaction now host:the michelle
malkin investigates michelle malkin you
look at all of this in detail all of
this here this guy six deportations he
was facing the federal government sent
to San Francisco turned her turn this
guy over and they refused to obey the
law Sean my outrage is laden with
melancholy because I have reported and
investigated on so many of these cases
over the last 25 years and there has
been so little if any accountability for
people in the federal state and local
government who have blood on their hands
Kate Steinle and her family never wanted
or wished for the publicity that they've
gotten the pain that they've suffered
and the fact that they have no choice
but to be front and center in the
headlines as they suffer as a result of
this verdict this really is I think a
damning indictment of so-called San
Francisco values where is Nancy Pelosi
tonight where has she been for the last
25 years this is her City and it is her
open borders policies that have haunted
so many innocent people in innocent
lives in San Francisco and it is the
conversion of America into a sanctuary
nation instead of a sovereign nation
that has endangered us and it is one of
the primary reasons that President Trump
was elected in the first place because
people made a choice after seeing this
fork in the road after seeing both
political parties Shawn both Republicans
and their big business donors and
Democrats and their identity politics
grievance mongers who don't care about
the rule of law in this country and the
collusion between those two things that
have created sanctuary policies and a
sanctuary nation that still exists to
this day when will this City and County
Sheriff in San Francisco and that mayor
and the governor ever be held
accountable for the deaths as a result
of his bloody open borders he spent much
of his life adult life behind closed
behind bars
six times as I said who's gonna be
taking up he actually said once he had
aimed at a sea animal he said at another
time that had fired when he stepped on
it I've been a pistol marksman since I'm
11 years old guns do not go off by
themselves there can be accidental
shootings a sea animal and then you
change his story here there's a word for
that that's called lying
that's called yes they're not even close
to being the same story that's right it
strains credulity the story that the
defense attorney told and let me get to
him in a moment with his comments after
the verdict was absolutely disgusting
some of what you showed but the idea
that he simply happened upon this weapon
and it was oopsie an accident when there
were witnesses that testified at the
trial that they saw him twirling the gun
around recklessly beforehand and then
scurrying away when the police were
looking for who it was that caused Kate
Steinle to fall to the ground and be
shot in the back when she was as you
said walking arm and arm with her father
on a happy day the idea that this
defense attorney now is politicizing
this verdict and rubbing salt into the
wounds of Kate Steinle zhh family it's
disgusting and it shows you the
mentality I think that probably infected
much of the jury did you know Sean that
any discussion of immigration policy and
Jose serratus five prior deportations
the detainer that was ignored by city
and county officials the pending six
deportation the seven felony convictions
including four narcotics convictions
none of that was allowed to be presented
to the jury
no wonder they ended up with the verdict
they did all right Michelle Malkin the
federal government had requested and
thank you for your time tonight